previously on TV sentence
the 70s little girl standing still and
staring away from the camera in a horror
genre cliche combined with a creepy
dilapidated house behind a wrought iron
fence on the horror genre cliche what
the hell good is this gate without a
corresponding fence why would you ever
even close are there occasions when you
don't want people using the actual brick
walkway this is a please walk in the
grass gate
[Music]
so they would be batting her ass and not
kicking it right just making sure I've
got my [ __ ] kids threatening a
physically and mentally disabled little
girl nomenclature down pat does this kid
have a never-ending supply of these bang
snaps did Willy Wonka invent an
everlasting bank snapper oh I always
wondered how the property brothers got
their start first off Tweedledee and
Tweedledum just passed a dead opossum so
that's probably the smell secondly even
if the smell is from a raccoon then why
would they want to find it he's [ __ ]
kids I have not wanted kids on film to
die so badly since the children of the
court who's down there what does this
kid mean by that why what do you think
it's anyone but his brother well that
went entirely exactly as expected today
when the hell is today like October 15th
2018 today like October 5th 2011 the day
this came out today more like some kind
of time shifting reality where whenever
the viewer sees it it automatically
becomes that day and the fashions cars
and pop-culture references and the show
all adjust accordingly today because if
it's that last one call me Jesus cuz I'm
taking away all the sins spoiler alert
it's not 35 joining me please why bother
calling the cops if you're gonna knife
investigate the intruder yourself and
why wouldn't the 911 operator tell her
to get out of the house if she could
well at least the show provides the
viewer with the opportunity to play the
Dylan McDermott Dermot Mulroney game if
they get bored and that's totally Dermot
right show has the gall to opening
credit on us for a full 20 seconds
before even showing us the first name
leading us to think we're watching
something important to the episode
before stabbing us with a giant maim
right in the eyeballs from the mine
behind Glee he comes yet another
traumatic and deeply disturbing look
into human psychosis the Oh Nick Dermot
has driven an actual car before right he
does know that occasionally you're
supposed to look at the actual road
instead of our second choice which was
sunshine come on it's funny it's not and
I don't it looks even better than mine
family moves into a new house at the
beginning of a horror story cliche the
show is horror movie cliche so hard I
wonder if it might actually be a parody
let's just tack on another 25 cliche
sins and move on shall we listen here
obvious clone of veer Farmiga you need
at least one brother a light bulb
powering uncle an eight-foot-tall Butler
a disembodied hand and a cousin with a
mountain of hair too even come close to
being one of the Addams Family so get it
right as you can see the previous owners
really love this place like a child they
restored everything so is that how they
treat their children in LA they restore
them let him do coke off your nipples
they were numb for like two days you
know what's a Ryan Murphy production
when even some of the random characters
off to the side are having one of the
Crassus [ __ ] conversations possible
down there is there some sort of
overacting award ceremony that I don't
know about because this girl is gunning
for the Nicolas Cage Lifetime
Achievement in facial and vocal exertion
in a scene that completely doesn't
required award you're gonna die in here
hey what are you doing she's that you're
gonna die in here girl of course all the
best neighborhoods in LA have one hi
I'm Constance your neighbor from next
door and this is my girl Adelaide nice
to see the neighbors pop in for some
heavy-handed foreshadowing an exposition
but you know who I'm getting the feeling
is never popping into this house
subtlety I wasn't about to have my green
pasture flash 70 feet high for every man
woman and child to see why is your
pasture green again is this an actual
euphemism I have never heard before or
just some writer who thought he was
writing a Lucky Charms commercial for a
second also why would there be kids
seeing your blue diamonds or orange
stars or red balloons or whatever the
hell you just said
get rid of some of that bad juju that
sounds racist oh you said juju yeah
thank our Christian God for subtitles
bad memories in here yeah I'm developing
my own set of them thank you very much
hey Dirk creepy attic
who'd a thunk it wait wait wait let me
guess what happens next she turns on the
light we get jumpscared by uh damn it I
said let me guess I swear was gonna say
hanging latex bodysuit SNM display I
really was I guess these guys were into
the kinky stuff with those powers of
deduction I can see why Ben got to be a
psychiatrist today huh
funny or very sanitary I'm not a
germaphobe but I'm sure it's not
sporting a [ __ ] suit found in an attic
without some serious 401 cleaning first
trust us while we wouldn't dare play it
the show is playing the Darryl Hanul
whistling song from Kill Bill which just
reminds us of a much better piece of
film that we would rather be watching
it's a filthy goddamn [ __ ] show show
accidentally includes a line from a
review as character dialogue dylan
mcdermott I work Monday through Thursday
Thanksgiving on Christmas all these are
some gullible ass people
Vivienne's somehow sues the realtor
wouldn't have mentioned the house comes
with a housekeeper and Ben is giving
sessions to a client who just seems to
appear at his house with no car the
Harmons may just deserve all this I kind
of a mess you'd never know well it's
kind of in the job description not sure
why no Hara is bragging about this in
the ongoing saga of dylan mcdermott
tries to act human while doing things I
submit to you banana eating holds and
eats a banana like that you gotta have
to forgive me one day in all of Ben's
dealings and teachings as a psychiatrist
does he not have a better approach than
this to making his wife get over his
infidelity you think I'm lying to you
light sensitivity isn't a side effect of
lexapro tape and lexapro is not what you
would prescribe to a person you thought
was suffering from psychosis since it's
an antidepressant and not an
anti-psychotic so maybe he's lying
because he knows you're a terrible
psychiatrist why'd you move here my dad
had an affair
feels like AHS and Maury Povich just
shared a writers room masturbation
followed by a more masturbation followed
by crying and ending with a man with a
half-burnt face being a peeping tom
cliche also he's gonna do that on a
table next to the window why not the
bathroom also also for the love of
Stephen King in under a minute we go
from an age shifting master major to
snazzy to face in the backyard too
creepy laughing bein a neighbor girl to
an O'Doyle twins reveal the show
understands drawing up tension about as
well as the Kardashians understand
eating cereal no I don't have this
social why doesn't Ben have Tate's
social I've never filled out a medical
form that didn't require it it's almost
like this take character isn't who he
says he is at least we know the show is
too clever to just have him be another
ghost right so do all women see older
Moira and all men see younger Moira and
why is that why would she even be able
to appear as two different versions of
herself all the other Murder House
ghosts appears the age they were when
they die I can't even look at your face
Ben without seeing the Express
on it while you were pile-driving her in
our bed I screwed up what is with the
overacting in this godforsaken show
I mean knob Dillon here has obviously
lost his mind but I know for a fact
Britain's Got Talent
and even she seems like she's forgotten
the definition of the word nuance
considering this takes up about 67% of
this pilot I'm guessing a lot look why
is this storyline even in here just give
them money troubles so they have to buy
whatever they can and then they get the
haunted out of an insane number of
ghosts and with these people is enough
drama to fill up 12 episodes we don't
need this soap opera nonsense you know I
can show you statistics and how many men
cheat after a miscarriage man that seems
like a delightful idea whoa come here
your face isn't the better question why
didn't the school at least clean up the
cut and maybe put a band-aid brand
bandage on even just to appear like they
care last thing on a television show for
more than a season or two would be my
best guess I'm not sure which one is
more fascinating that Mommy Dearest here
has been cleaning this wound for about a
minute and it still looks exactly the
same or that her daughter has inflicted
even once with direct contact to an open
wound with peroxide you simply walk up
to her and say here's the deal I need
you just stop harassing me I got what
you want drugs
this chick being such a cokehead she'd
willingly walk into a creepy house where
a girl she hates supposedly sells the
drugs comes out of nowhere and yeah I
remember that snorted coke off my
nipples comment that's all I remember
clear eyes full hearts people clear eyes
full hearts one positive from this
series is that if you're a gun that
doesn't like cold showers or thinking
about baseball you can just picture a
sex scene from this show and you won't
be able to get it up for at least a
month no there's no time so here's the
lowdown Tammy Taylor is having latex
bodysuit sex with an unknown suitor
upstairs while Bobby Donnell who's
trying to burn his hand downstairs but
has his plan thwarted by the creepy
patsy cline meanwhile their daughter is
being coached by brick silver on how to
be the friendly neighborhood psychopath
I know this show is trying to get me to
care about all these things so I'll
watch another episode but I can't
imagine anything I could care less about
right now jump cut another jump cut jump
cut - a car trunk strange angle from
overhead go back Zoom shaky-cam zoom
behold the fury of greed peeking in
people's windows is still a crime even
in LA well technically recording them
without consent is illegal but in most
places simple looking through a window
without dress
passing wouldn't likely be prosecuted so
I've heard how do you put you have to be
sleeping to not wake up when gasoline
was literally poured all over you like
convenient plot reasons deep I'm
guessing why is it that it is always the
old [ __ ] who acts the part of a
moralistic prude
I believe that's referred to as the
circle of life you only like Indian food
when you're pregnant she found this out
just one day after the sexcapades
that's pretty good what you hate trees I
wasn't about to have my green pasture
flash 70 feet high I was up for Princess
Leia how was this close so who gets it
the one who sleeps with George Lucas
sometimes people just go mad we all go a
little mad sometimes their eyes full
hearts can't lose
Marge Simpson sold her first house the
manor house